How are you doing? How's your Friday? It's going well. How about yours? Incredible. I'm so excited. You know, just do this and then finish this build, get those pillars together, you know, and just, you know, blow Margie, I remember that Margie, blow her socks off, blow Paula's socks off, blow your socks off, and then, you know, hopefully make this a fruitful relationship where I help you guys with clients and, you know, their web designs or whatever it is.
Yeah, I'm super excited. So we can kind of just get into it. I don't think it's going to take that long. Honestly, you definitely don't need the whole hour. Okay, great. Cool. So I'm just gonna get right into it. So I sent you a PDF. Do you want to pull it up? Yep, I'm looking at it. If you can't even see my screen, right? If I share it doesn't help you. No, but I'm looking at it. All right. So you could just honestly skip to the you could always type it in.
Tell when something's AI generated, like real quickly, because I'm like, Oh, I had to get like, my notes together. So you can just like, kind of see it. I'm pretty good at like, on slopping it, as they say, but this one's pretty ass. But yeah, it's just because it's a questionnaire. So if you just go skip to page four, where it just says ask for the truth. Those are these are all of the questions, these next two pages, if you just want to go through all of these hammer them out, that is probably the easiest way to
save you time and me time. Because I actually have an 1115. I have a hard stop. So okay. All right. So in terms of positioning and market fit, which custom home builders are the best fit for big orange? I'm gonna back up a second, because it's not even necessarily custom home builders, custom home builders are folks, I don't know if you're familiar with the industry at all, but I am a little bit. Yes. Okay, so custom home builders are people building, you know, truly one of a kind design houses for people, typically on their own land.
There are also production home builders, which we would also be able to serve. Those are people that tend to own or have developed a community or the single builder in a community. And they're cranking out
I mean, the value varies depending on where you live, but like the 400 to $800,000 houses that people come in, maybe they can choose a countertop color or paint color, but they're not they're not choosing every item in the house. So we can work with custom home builders, we could work with production builders.
So which ones are the best fit? If they're a custom home builder, I think Margie's cut off point is like 12 million. It may dip down to like eight. And that would be for a custom home builder. Some of these guys are only like the custom home builder, we just started working with, they're only doing four to six projects a year. So pretty small.
But they obviously when you're working with someone for two years, you need to keep your pipeline pretty, you know, revved up because like this builder we're working with now, in the summer, especially he's concentrating on building because they're in North Dakota. So he's not doing the sales. I'm probably skipping into some other question you have.
But evening out peaks and valleys of leads is, you know, somebody needs that, that we can help. So your next question, what's happening in their business when they start looking for marketing help? Typically, it's been a couple of different things.
Secession is a big one. A lot of these builders are older, they're looking to hand off the business to either someone in their family, or maybe they're going to sell it or hand it to an employee. So it might be something like that generational change.
And it could be that their leads are drying up, and they're concerned. Possibly they've never worked with a marketing company before. Or they they have somebody in house who's trying to do it. Maybe that person's leaving or maybe that person is just stretched too thin. Like, if somebody in house thinks they're going to be able to keep up with blog writing and social media writing, it's probably not going to happen unless that's
really set into their job description. Like if it's the person who's also doing something else, that's not going to work very well. On the other hand, I think a lot of these builders look at marketing and think that's just BS, I can do it myself.
Which is always really, really funny. And then that's when you bring me into a call. And then 10 minutes later, they're gonna be like, Oh, I'm wrong. I never tell a client they're wrong, though, just to be very clear, I will never, ever, ever tell a client doesn't matter if they're a home builder doesn't matter what space they're in, I always will just defer to their industry expertise, obviously, and I just give them strategy advice. That's how I always approach it personally. But yeah, it's funny, because they do need marketing.
They absolutely need marketing. There's such a high ROI on it for them to absolutely. And you know, maybe six years ago, they did their website. So in their mind, we just did our website. Right? Yeah, so that was pandemic carry. Yeah, yeah. Right. Yeah. Or they've, they've always gotten word of mouth referrals. That's what they've been leaning on. And maybe those aren't happening the way they used to.
Okay, which market markets project types and builder profiles matter most. I think the only limitations are we can't also have another similar builder in the same regional market. I think that, you know, I, if there's a place in the country that buildings not happening, and you know, it's people aren't wanting to live there, then clearly, that wouldn't be a good market.
But nope. Yeah, one of the builders were building or we're working with in Utah is a big second home market for folks from Las Vegas. So you know, those kinds of things are interesting. People with money wanting to build a second home project types.
These aren't usually, well, it's hard to say because we have had some, we have some developments where people are building smaller, like what they call patio homes. And those are for folks who are downsizing.
They usually own the house, but they don't have to worry about the exterior maintenance. So that's really attractive to certain demographic.
So even though those houses might not be really big or ostentatious, the development can use marketing help. And they're popular market or housing type, even though the particular specific house value isn't as high as like with a ultra luxury custom home builder.
Okay.
Yeah, that makes sense.
So we've worked with both builders and developers. Sometimes when a developer goes in, they create a new community. They want to create a website for that community. It's smart to do that.
And so those tend to not be ongoing projects. We do have one that has been ongoing. It's a master plan community. So new neighborhoods are opening up all the time in that development.
So that's more ongoing. Some developments, they might have 36 lots. As soon as those sell out or get close to selling out, that development isn't, you know, those developers aren't real interested in keeping up, you know, a really active website.
So, but getting in when the developer is just starting to market the development, we can do that too. What makes a builder a poor fit? So many things they can do it themselves and doesn't see the need.
Oh, yeah, I figured you'd work on a street.
Right. Yeah. And, you know, it can be an old school thing too. Sometimes like a second generation might be a better fit.
But yeah, or a builder who's new. I'm sure you can probably guess at this. They think that, you know, the old ways that they've always marketed are fine.
What do ideal clients already understand? Where do they need education? They might already understand that digital presence is important.
They might not understand really how social media works, but if they do, that's great. If they're willing to videotape them, if they can record themselves with a behind the scenes, that's great.
Great evergreen content for sure. Definitely something you can mass disseminate across a multitude of months just off of 20 minutes of filming.
And I tell that to clients all the time. And it's so funny Janice, they'll be like, I never thought of that. Do you guys want to come on site? We're like, yeah.
And then we'll send our crew for momentum to go on site. Usually they're Philadelphia businesses. And then they'll shoot. We did one for a lawyer.
It was so random. It wasn't anything. It was just like we went in the office. I didn't go in, obviously, but they just went in. And it was just like, I don't even know everything in entail, but I know they got like 11 different pieces of content.
And they were only there for 15 minutes. So it's absolutely couldn't agree more. Right.
We had one builder and we said, hey, you just got this shipment of these cool tiles and do an unboxing video. And, you know, for them, that was just foreign territory.
Like, why would anybody want to watch us open a box of tile?
Other education, oftentimes with these folks who are only working with a limited number of clients at one time, may not have a very robust CRM system.
So trying to show them the benefits of that instead of just tracking on a literally on a spreadsheet, you know, who this person called in.
Did anybody call them back? What did we tell them? So that kind of sales enablement education. We are happy to do that as well.
So and to kind of help them figure out what's a good CRM to use. A lot of them, if we can get them on HubSpot, then that can roll in their email newsletter as well.
You know, anybody who's still using MailChimp or whatever, there's just better tools and, you know, they may be paying for some different things like that that they could consolidate.
So there's some education there.
By your trust and differentiation. What makes a homeowner trust one builder enough to make contact?
I would say word of mouth, website, social media that makes them look like they're an active concern, you know, that they're not, that they're out there.
Homoramas for a lot of these builders are helpful, you know, if they see a parade of homes, they see their work at a parade of homes.
I don't know if in your area what they might call this thing, but it, you know, it's basically where people are building show homes and you walk through them.
So that's helpful.
Most of our folks don't do like home shows anymore, but a production builder probably still would.
I think this is really personality driven, especially on the custom home builder side, because when you sign up with one of these people, you're working with them and their team pretty closely for like two years.
If you don't like that person, it's not going to be pleasant.
So, yeah.
For sure.
I'm just laughing. Your answers are just making me laugh because I'm just like, yep, that's what I'm thinking in my head.
Which proof matters most before a consultation?
I think when people are just looking and they're before they've even met somebody, I think they're looking at projects.
You know, people love to look at photos of what someone else has done or what the builder has done.
I think reviews, video testimonials on people's own websites, I think might go a little farther than Google reviews.
I don't know. I'm at the point where I take Google reviews with a grain of salt and I don't know, maybe not everybody does.
I think that there's probably some older customers who don't look at them at all.
They are more of the, I want to meet the person.
And if we click, that's going to help.
Pricing guidance, it's such a, in the custom home side, it's confusing.
And if there's something that we can put on the website that helps make that feel simpler, I think that's helpful.
But, boy, if they don't have good photos of knockout projects, I think they're stymied.
What makes builder positioning sound interchangeable?
Tell me what you think that question means.
That one was ambiguous, honestly, for me.
I honestly wasn't really sure how to interpret it, so I was kind of leaving the interpretation up to you.
So maybe what they're trying to say here is, if you go on every builder site, everyone is going to say, we have meticulous craftsmanship, we have great designs,
we walk with you through the process.
I guess those three things all kind of sound the same.
I can't imagine a builder not saying that they would do those three things.
So yeah, I think those are probably some traps that people fall into, and trying to tease out a more interesting story is helpful.
How do you uncover the real difference that deserves to be marketed?
I think that's just a lot of conversation with the builders trying to get to know.
We spend a month with a new client.
Obviously, we're not doing this every day, but we meet with them weekly for the first month, talk to their customers, interview their customers with some pretty marketing-specific questions,
and then try to really suss out who are their ideal customers.
What do they want more of?
And ask these builders, what do you think sets you apart?
We have one builder that says, well, it's the fact that I've got a team that every customer works with.
They're not going to feel like they're on their own.
We have another builder who says, I work with every customer, so you're going to get my time.
Obviously, with a production builder, that's not going to work.
So I guess uncovering the real difference just involves us asking a lot of questions, listening, and looking for what makes them stand out either from their peers or in their region, I guess.
I guess both of those are for builders, never mind.
And again, the difference is in the product, right?
A lot of it comes back to great photos of outstanding work.
When do referrals stop being a sufficient growth system?
I don't know that I can really quantify that.
I mean, I guess when the leads dry up, right?
And if you're hoping to capitalize on people who are relocating to your area, referrals, I think, are maybe not as helpful.
So the community that I talked about, the folks that built the master plan community, they would really like to hit a lot of people who are moving to Cincinnati for their jobs or for other reasons.
So that kind of person who's just showing up in a city, they probably don't have that network to ask, you know, who's your builder, who built your house?
So that, in that case, referrals may not be sufficient if they're going for a real market or if they want to, if they're looking to level up or, you know, maybe they've been doing kind of 50-50 renovations and home building,
but they really want to skew more toward renovations.
You know, maybe then they need more than just referrals because they've had more home building clients and not as many renovations. I don't know.
What must a builder website prove above the fold that they've got beautiful work?
I think that's, I don't even know if people read the copy. I think they just want to see the pictures.
I agree.
What project details of photography are most persuasive?
People love to see the kitchens. Good vignette, detailed photos in kitchens are good.
Photography that's professional and style. I mean, we never get styled, but at least we get professional, which is helpful.
And I don't know if you know what I mean by that, but like if somebody's really doing like magazine type photography, they'll bring in a photographer, they'll also bring in a stylist, who's one doing, you know, putting flowers out on the countertop or making it look like someone's actually sitting down to a meal
instead of just an empty table. So we don't usually get styled, but at least you get professional.
And that makes all the difference because if it's just someone in there, builders love to go in and take photographs of their work when they're done.
But they do it before anybody moves in because they don't want to be a hassle to the homeowner, right?
Like at that point the homeowner wants them out of their lives. So they don't want to go back in and say, hey, do you mind if we take photos?
But it really is important to get those photos when the place is finished and furnished.
So even if you can't get great exterior photos and once the landscaping is in, and we can even help them if the landscaping is not in, there's tricks.
You just go in and take it at twilight or at night and turn on all the lights.
And no one can tell if the grass is there, but you can see that the house is beautiful.
Along the way, like behind the scenes, stuff is also really good, too.
We've got this one builder who's good about going onto a job site and saying, hey, look, our windows are in and here's why these windows are great.
And here's what's coming up next. Like that kind of photography is great, too, because people like to see the process.
So it doesn't have to be finished and furnished. If they can do some behind the scenes stuff that has interest, that's good, too.
What pages or answers are almost always missing? Well, nobody likes to talk about pricing unless it's a production builder.
They usually have houses for sale and those tend to be the prices. The price range, at least, is usually there for custom builders and renovators.
They're going to hesitate to give any kind of numbers because it varies so widely.
We want to push people for AEO reasons to at least give a range, but that can be a hard sell because they don't want to turn anybody off.
But if you're a custom home builder doing 1.5 to 2.57, whatever, you don't want to be taking calls from people who are looking for a $400,000 house.
So I'd like them to put in more information about pricing, but that's a tough sell.
Other answers are almost always missing.
I think a good, robust blog section helps answer some questions for people, like what's involved with site work before construction begins?
Do I need to pull my own permits? Do I have to hire a separate architect?
Questions like that that can be answered by a blog or can be sent out to prospects by an email newsletter, those are helpful, I think.
Or that's the kind of thing that somebody could answer in a quick video that we could put on social.
Do I have to pull my own permits? No, we take care of that for you. That's a quick social media post.
What homeowner questions deserve a direct public answer?
I think there's always questions about the relationship between design and construction.
A lot of the custom home builders are design build firms, so they have the designer in-house.
And you just come to them, describe your house. They design it for you and then they build it.
Other super high-end places, you go get an architect, you get the designed, and the architect might help you find a builder.
The architect's supposed to be your advocate with the builder.
If you're a production person, production builder, typically your design work is all done in-house too, and they just have kind of stock floor plans.
I think questions about how that design process works deserve a public answer.
People probably have questions about land purchases. If it's a custom builder, do I have to bring my own lot?
Do you help me purchase a lot? I'm sure there's others.
Which sales objection should this page answer in plain English?
So you're talking about the service page that I guess I'm confused about.
Which sales objection for the builder looking for marketing or the people looking for a builder?
I think looking for the marketing.
I think you could kind of skew it toward the, you can't do this all yourself, right?
And I think an easy way to do that is you're not doing, you're not pounding every nail in the house you're building.
So you're contracting out. This is another part of your business that you can contract out.
You don't have to do it all yourself.
What other sales objections do the builders have?
Referrals, word of mouth.
And I think we've covered that why that's really not true.
My work should speak for itself. I shouldn't have to do any of this marketing.
The problem with that is, who's seeing your work, right?
Is it a limited number of people? Are new people, when they're looking for a builder, seeing your work?
How would they find you if you're not marketing?
A hundred percent.
I mean, of course, I think almost always they're like, what am I going to get for my money?
They're very money conscious. The margins are, I think, pretty slim.
I would be just and they get, you know, like now there's new tariffs on plywood, right?
So a lot of stuff is out of their control.
So they're going to be very conscious of how much marketing costs.
Is that all lumber fall under that for the custom builds? I wasn't sure if it was.
Yes, anything.
Two separate tariffs on those. And I know aluminum got tariffs.
I'm sure aluminum plays a little bit of a role somewhere in the house.
You know, some of these people who are building high end, they're getting their tile from Italy.
There's a lot of as well as supply line concerns.
I think supply line has gotten a little better pandemic that was awful.
But yeah, there's a lot of the costs that are completely out of their control.
So marketing probably seems like a cost they can control.
And I am sure it feels like an easy one to axe when it gets tight.
I don't know how to really spin that one.
Yeah, it's all good.
All right. Did you have the follow-up?
You said trust. What specifically makes a homeowner believe that?
Was that a question for her? For me? Oh, question.
No, that's just, yeah, let's ignore that.
Oh boy, there's still more. And I know you have a hard stop.
Yes, it's okay. It's okay.
Ten minutes. How do builders describe their marketing project types in real conversations?
I mean, they use words like move up buyers, custom home, executive homes, estates, luxury, those kind of words.
What local proof is both honest and useful? Video testimonies, working at, you know, showing their work at these parades of homes or homoramas.
What should a search engine or AI answer engine understand about a big orange builder client?
I think that one's probably a little bit. That's like, that one made me laugh when I was looking at it.
Because that's such a like subjective answer, in my opinion, because it's always changing.
I thought it should have been 26 questions because when I saw that, I was like, you can't really, I mean, I'm curious. What do you think?
What should a search engine understand about a big orange builder client?
But they may not. It's all keyword. It's all keyword related. So it's like, that's what drives it. That's what makes me laugh.
And there may not be, they may not be very tech savvy either. So I don't know that a lot of them are using AI.
Personally, this is what I think. I think it should just be like, very, I'm trying to like, I mean, I still, I have nine minutes, but I just wanted to be like, I'll try to give like a quick answer on this.
But basically, as long as you're providing educational content, proper keywords, that's all that matters. That's, that's what I think.
Yeah. And I realized after I was talking about that last question, we would work with remodelers too, and I haven't mentioned.
Okay. Okay. So, but I don't, maybe, maybe for this particular pillar, we stick with that home builder.
I want to go a 20 real quick. What should count as a qualified builder lead? I think it's marketing qualified. Like they showed up, they raised their hands.
If they aren't the kind of person who can afford that kind of house, then, you know, that's a, that's a positioning thing that we should look at. But that's a lead.
I'm QL. What can marketing own? What still depends on sales follow up? Well, we can bring in the leads, but you know, if they're not doing the sales work that they should be doing, then it's, it's important that they follow up.
I just made a drum noise in the back because it's what I always tell clients. I'm like, look, you know, we can bring you leads. Trust me, we will bring you leads.
Right. Right.